[Music]
in 132 Cee Chinese polymath Zhang hung
presented the Han Court with his latest
invention
this large vase he claimed could tell
them whenever an earthquake occurred in
their kingdom including the direction
they should send aid the court was
somewhat skeptical especially when the
device triggered on a seemingly quiet
afternoon but when messengers came for
help
days later their doubts turned to
gratitude today we no longer rely on
pots to identify seismic events but
earthquakes still offer a unique
challenge to those trying to track them
so why are quakes so hard to anticipate
and how could we get better at
predicting them to answer that we need
to understand some theories behind how
earthquakes occur Earth's crust is made
from several vast jagged slabs of rock
called tectonic plates each riding on a
hot partially molten layer of Earth's
mantle
this causes the plates to spread very
slowly at anywhere from 1 to 20
centimeters per year but these tiny
movements are powerful enough to cause
deep cracks in the interacting plates
and in unstable zones the intensifying
pressure may ultimately trigger an
earthquake it's hard enough to monitor
these miniscule movements but the
factors that turn shifts into seismic
events are far more varied different
fault lines juxtapose different rocks
some of which are stronger or weaker
under pressure diverse rocks also react
differently to friction and high
temperatures some partially melt and can
release lubricating fluids made of
superheated minerals that reduce
faultline friction but some are left dry
prone to dangerous buildups of pressure
and all these faults are subject to
varying gravitational forces as well as
the currents of hot rocks moving
throughout Earth's mantle so which of
these hidden variables should we be
analyzing and how do they fit in to our
growing prediction toolkit because some
of these forces occur at largely
constant rates the behavior of the
plates is somewhat cyclical today many
of our most reliable Clues come from
long-term forecasting related to when
and where earthquakes have previously
occurred at the scale of millennia this
allows us to make predictions about when
highly active faults like the San
Andreas are overdue for a massive
earthquake but due to the many variables
involved this method can only predict
very loose timeframes to predict more
imminent events researchers have
investigated the vibrations earth
elicits before a quake geologists have
long used seismometers to track and map
these tiny shifts in the Earth's crust
and today most smartphones are also
capable of recording primary seismic
waves with a network of phones around
the globe
scientists could potentially crowdsource
a rich detailed warning system that
alerts people to incoming quakes
unfortunately phones might not be able
to provide the advanced notice needed to
enact safety protocols but such detailed
readings would still be useful for
prediction tools like NASA's quake sim
software which can use a rigorous blend
of geological data to identify regions
at risk however recent studies indicate
the most telling signs of a quake might
be invisible to all these sensors in
2011 just before an earthquake struck
the east coast of Japan nearby
researchers recorded surprisingly high
concentrations of the radioactive
isotope pair radon and thoron as stress
builds up in the crust right before an
earthquake micro fractures allow these
gases to escape to the surface these
scientists think that if we built a vast
network of radon thoron detectors in
earthquake prone areas it could become a
promising warning system
potentially predicting quakes a week in
advance of course none of these
technologies would be as helpful as
simply looking deep inside the earth
itself with a deeper view we might be
able to track and predict large-scale
geological changes in real time possibly
saving tens of thousands of lives a year
but for now these technologies can help
us prepare and respond quickly to areas
in need without waiting for directions
from a vase keep exploring the
terrifying power of nature with this
playlist